hey David does the hashtag never Biden
movement helped or hurt progressives so
there are elements to this question that
are similar to the elements of whether
the progressive a wing of the Democratic
Party should simply separate from the
Democratic Party altogether
first and foremost the never Biden
people who insist Biden can't win these
are the exact same folks who believed
even when it was very clear Bernie had
no shot to the nomination that Bernie
was going to be the nominee so in terms
of their ability to do political
prognostication I would not put too much
weight behind the opinions of the
hashtag never Biden movement but I think
that they bring an important question to
the table which is over the long term
over the long term does the progressive
movement benefit or not from Joe Biden
winning in 2020 now I did a segment
about this a couple of months ago I am
no stranger to this idea if you sort of
take a game theory perspective you can
argue that the best thing for
progressives is for Biden to be the
nominee but to lose to Trump why could
that be the best thing for progressives
over the long term this is theoretical
well Biden's the nominee and loses it
gives progressives the strongest
position to say we told you we told you
an establishment Democrat can't win we
need an actual progressive as the
nominee and it would potentially
position a real progressive for 2024 to
potentially become the next president of
the United States after Donald Trump's
second term right that's the game theory
question now in practical terms how much
damage is done for decades if Donald
Trump gets to pick one or two more
Supreme Court justices during his second
term well that's not trivial how much
damage is done to the environment if we
get four years of Trump versus four
years of Biden who supports the green
New Deal as a framework if not fully
admittedly how much does our economy
suffer
we get four more years of Donald Trump's
tax plan as opposed to Joe Biden's which
is better on marginal tax rates which is
better on the taxing of capital gains I
could go on so I believe that if you
want to ignore the damage and
destruction that Donald Trump will do in
a second term in a game theory
hypothetical perspective there is a very
good case to be made that in the long
run maybe the progressive movement is
more jump-started by Biden losing in
November than winning in practical terms
as a person who gets one vote and has
the decision to make
do I take an action that reinstalls
Trump or do I take an action that
removes him I have to vote for Joe Biden
that's my moral compass I can't take an
action that would make it more likely
Trump gets four more years and this gets
us to incremental ISM versus
acceleration ISM when I look at history
and I've done this before I won't I
won't bore people by doing it again when
people say hey let's let's burn it down
to build it back up I don't see
instances in the last hundred and fifty
years of American history where that was
actually what worked other than through
Cataclysm and massive death when we look
at the Progressive Era the New Deal era
and the civil rights era yes there were
protests yes there there was some
violence yes and I'm not minimizing it
by saying some I I don't mean what I
mean is in the grand scheme of things
those were advances that happened
because of peaceful protests because of
who was on the Supreme Court at the time
and was able to uphold some of those
changes so the theoretical question of
the long term progressive movements of
success if Biden loses versus if he wins
let's do it when it comes to November I
can't take an action that helps Donald
Trump okay
last question today hey David are you
worried about violence if Donald Trump
loses in November I want to be really
careful when talking about this because
I I worry that I'm stepping into
minefield where I might be giving people
ideas and I really don't want to do that
which is why I've sort of resisted
talking about this but I think at this
point it deserves some discussion
okay let's game it out Joe Biden wins by
a lot
what do trumpets do Joe Biden wins by a
tiny bit
what do Trump is do I actually think the
more dangerous scenario is if Biden wins
by a little bit because if Biden really
just crushes Donald Trump my instinct is
that you will see Trump ist's sort of
just like pretend nothing ever happened
and say hey you know coronavirus was a
unique circumstance this isn't really a
big loss for Trump this was you know
people voting because of a pandemic that
affected every country this doesn't say
anything about Trump okay Biden's the
president good luck with that guys and I
think you would see trumpets be
relatively quiet if Biden absolutely
blows out Donald Trump now more likely
is that it's gonna be a maybe a closer
election no matter who wins the scenario
that scares me is if Biden wins very
narrowly very very narrowly and Trump
fuels the idea that something unfair
happened that's something that the
election cannot be trusted that the
results have been doctored that it was
rigged in some way that's the scenario
that really scares me particularly in
the period between election day and what
would be Joe Biden's inauguration day
that period in my mind could become one
of these where you you want to stay home
when the virus is spreading maybe you
would want to stay home during that as
well in certain parts of the country I
believe that law enforcement locally
state federally is more than equipped to
handle it but that doesn't mean that
there could not be dangers and yes it is
something I'm thinking of and I am
hopeful that it does not go that way if
Trump wins I think it's less likely that
you see that violence I think the
scenario most likely to lead to violence
would be a narrow Biden victory which
Trump casts doubt on the integrity of
the election in a way
that really gets his base going and
going crazy I hope I'm wrong let me know
your thoughts about what you expect what
you think there we've got a fantastic
bonus show for you today it is Friday
meaning producer Pat Forde
is taking the reins of the bonus show so
that's it for me for the week I will be
back with you on Monday what if you
could read 10 books in just one sitting
that's exactly what one of my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinka
stand what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books they condense
them down into text or audio that you
can consume in 15 minutes blinka snakes
sure that you're getting all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for there's
a full book you're thinking about buying
you can use blink as' to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink accom
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video